they can't keep secrets i i think it's
because letting them out is the best
it's the best feeling it's one of life's
true joys letting out a secret letting
out a secret is like dropping off a
first date and as soon as she gets in
her house farting alone in your car
do not back away from a smart fart joke
that is a smart fart joke
it's true the release it's real it's
authentic it feels fantastic
that's a real moment of joy the only
risk you run when telling a secret to
somebody is you might run into the one
guy who already knows the secret
isn't that a killjoy
just at a party like hey jim
jim
hey jim
jimmy
jim jim
jim joe
guess what
then jim's like
karen's pregnant with her boss's baby
just betrayed you on so many levels one
they didn't let you have the joy of
telling them the secret and two they
knew the secret before you knew and
didn't tell you
what kind of disciplined lunatic keeps a
secret
this is what it is if i can trust you to
keep a secret i don't trust you you joy
withholding vulcan computer person
gym
getting mad at the person i made up gm
i'm saying normal people can't keep
secrets in fact the best counter
argument to any conspiracy theory i've
ever heard is that people can't keep
secrets you know what i mean you're
telling me an alien landed in lincoln
nebraska and fingered the mayor
you tried to think of something alienate
you know what i mean
and you're telling me that not one of
the guys in the hazmat suits cleaning up
the mess told anyone
i mean how's he gonna keep that in
he's a hazmat cleanup guy
what does he work three days a year
alien landing corporate chemical spill
rowdy bar mitzvah he's off the rest of
the year
so that's 362 days of him sitting
quietly with his wife of 40 years
grasping for conversation
there's only so many silent dinners you
can withstand before you're gonna be
like oh
trish this lasagna is it's great
this is great is this is oh
is this ricotta
see how it's good it's good it's good
ricotta is a standard it's a standard
it's a standard
lasagna cheese you know
you you got it you got a ricotta
you have got to recap too
if you want a cheese to please
trish i saw an alien finger the mayor